you look terrible I said I know they're
great no you're one dedicated actor Ryan
Gosling you go above and beyond to bring
your characters to life on the screen
but sometimes your vision clashes with
the director's vision and things get a
little messy you put your body through a
lot to look the part like that time you
gain 60 pounds to play Jack salmon in
the lovely bones only to be dropped by
Peter Jackson because you've gained too
much weight you got replaced by Mark
Wahlberg and then suddenly you were out
of shape and unemployed disorder and
actors transform their bodies when
preparing for certain roles they'll pack
on the pounds or cut down on calories to
embody their characters we've got ten of
the most extreme body transformations
lined up for you keep watching to find
out which actor suffered both mentally
and physically
while preparing for her role it was the
hardest thing I've ever done no one
knows more about transforming their body
than Australian actor Chris Hemsworth
although he usually keeps in shape Chris
has had to push himself to develop his
muscles for certain movie roles back in
2011 Chris was cast as the almighty Thor
and would go on to star in a handful of
Marvel productions but the role wasn't
just handed to him he had to prove that
he could follow a strict diet and
workout plan before the camera started
rolling Chris revealed that he had to
gain about 25 pounds of solid muscle to
play Thor training for about six right
months for that first film but according
to the actor bulking up is a whole lot
easier than bulking down which is
something he's also had to do throughout
his career Chris who is 6 feet 3 inches
tall tends to weigh about 215 pounds
when portraying Thor but in 2015 he
slimmed down quite a bit to star in
black hat in that same year Chris had to
lose an additional 15 pounds to be cast
as Owen in the heart of the sea Chris
eat 500 calories a day for about a month
to prepare for the role while
maintaining a daily workout by the end
of the movie Chris weighed under a
hundred and eighty pounds when it comes
to his lost at sea diet the actor says
he wouldn't recommend it on mr. chase
thank you sir never do they have much
meditation woman back in 2011 Rooney
Mara was cast as the dark and
intelligent hacker Lisbeth Salander in
The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo
but transforming into Lisbeth proved to
be a lot more difficult than Rooney had
initially predicted luckily she was up
for the challenge she wanted to embody
Lisbeth as closely as possible which led
her to opt for a real life piercings
instead of cosmetic ones rooney got
multiple ear piercings done she also
pierced her nose eyebrows lips and other
parts of her body for the role then
Rooney died and cut her hair and even
bleached her eyebrows the gorgeous actor
who already had a slender physique also
decided to shed some weight seeing as
Lisbeth was described as anorexic in the
books the contrary to popular belief
Bruni chose to lose weight on her own
accord
and not because director david fincher
had asked her to so while her co-star
Daniel Craig gained weight to portray
his character Rooney all but starved
herself to play Lisbeth just like his
romantic partner Rooney Mara
Joaquin Phoenix knows a thing or two
about method acting and drastic
transformations Joaquin is an actor who
goes all-in when preparing for a role
he's lost weight he's gained weight and
he stayed in character for months on end
most recently in 2019 Joaquin portrayed
Arthur Fleck in the Joker can you
introduce me as Joker but to do his
character justice he had to shed an
insane amount of weight all in all
Joaquin lost a whopping 52 pounds while
preparing for the movie the severe
weight loss impacted him both physically
and mentally
at one point Joaquin even feared that he
was developing an eating disorder as he
became obsessed with counting calories
and weighing himself
Joaquin took things even further by
losing this much weight in just a few
months he found out he had been chosen
to play Arthur Fleck in July and
completely transformed himself by the
time production started in September
how's it going guys come on
in 2018 shailene woodley portrayed Tammy
Oldham in a drift the movie was based on
real life events beckoning Shailene and
her co-star sam claflin to make some big
lifestyle changes both shaylen and sam
were made to lose weight as their
characters would be stuck at sea for
days on end with minimal supplies she
was given the impossible task of
slimming down while working out her
character who would be lost at sea for
41 days would spend most of her time
sailing through stormy waters so playing
the role of Tammy required a lot of
upper body strength which is something
shaylen didn't have the actor worked out
her top path by swimming an hour every
single day on top of that she
drastically slimmed down by eating no
more than 350 calories a day her daily
diet which lasted for over a month
consisted of a can of salmon two egg
yolks and steamed vegetables but keeping
her measly 350 calories down proved to
be even more challenging than dieting
itself as she experienced a lot of
motion sickness while filming adrift
fifty son whose real name is Curtis
Jackson in case you were wondering has
made the jump from rapping to acting a
handful of times and he's proven himself
to be as dedicated as some of the greats
in 2011 50 portrayed Dion in All Things
Fall Apart the movie centers around a
promising football player who gets
diagnosed with cancer this movie was
near and dear to 50 s heart as he had a
friend who passed away from cancer and
he wanted to pay him tribute everyone
was shocked when a picture of 50 began
circling the internet in 2011 he looked
sickly and thin causing rumors to fly
around but as it turned out 50 had just
recently lost over 50 pounds for a movie
role he went from being 214 pounds to
160 pounds in just nine short weeks he
accomplished this by liquid dieting and
running up to three hours a day fifties
transformation was mind-blowing and
although he didn't win any awards for
his performance he's happy with how the
movie turned out after all All Things
Fall Apart was a passion project for the
famed rapper
you want to do it on your own terms
that's a question Chris Pat is well
known for playing Andy Dwyer on the
hilarious TV show Parks and Recreation
but while he was still portraying this
character Chris auditioned for the role
of Peter quill in guardians of the
galaxy and he landed the part on one
condition
Chris had to shed a large sum of weight
while gaining muscle to transform into
the Marvel hero star-lord so we got to
work and completely transformed his body
in just six short months Chris lost a
total of 60 pounds scoring himself a
six-pack in the process to achieve his
desired body type Chris worked out every
single day combining running swimming
boxing and weight training with a
healthy diet Chris worked with reputable
celebrity trainers while prepping for
the Marvel movie his weight loss
transformation startled his fans who
were used to seeing him as the lovable
and slightly overweight Andy Dwyer keep
watching to find out which model turned
actor gained loads of weight for her
breakthrough role in 2010 Mila Kunis
portrayed Lily in Black Swan which
proved to be an unforgettable experience
in more ways than one Mila who considers
herself to be a huge foodie had to slim
down quite a bit for a role seeing as
her character was a trained pal arena
problem was Mila didn't have much weight
to lose to begin with she was only a
hundred and fifteen pounds when she took
on the role still she set out to lose 20
pounds over the course of five months
and succeeded Mila admitted that her
weight loss approach hadn't been
sustainable or healthy after all she was
eating under 1200 calories a day while
exercising five hours a day seven times
a week Mila also trained to dance like a
real-life ballerina which made sticking
to her diet all the more exhausting I
dislocated my shoulder I have two scars
on my back and it was worth every minute
award-winning actor Matt Damon is
someone who doesn't mess around when
preparing for a role he's gained and
lost week to resemble his characters
some of which were more challenging than
others you might think that Matt's most
challenging role was the one of Mark
Watney in the Martian but that isn't the
case sure mark did lose a bunch of
weight while being stranded on Mars but
Matt didn't have to lose a pound while
shooting the film although Matt was
prepared to shed 30 to 40 pounds
director Ridley Scott forbade it instead
he chose to use CGI to alter Matt's
appearance and this came as a relief as
Matt had once nearly lost his life while
losing weight for the 1996 film courage
under fire going through life without
thinking about the consequences for
three straight months Matt eat nothing
but chicken while running 13 miles a day
he lost 50 pounds in three months going
from a hundred and ninety to 139 pounds
without ever consulting a nutritionist
or a doctor back in 2013 Jared was cast
as ray on an hiv-positive transsexual
woman in the movie Dallas buyers club
but to get into character Jared had to
lose a lot of weed the thirty Seconds to
Mars singer hadn't taken on a role in
over four years at the time but he fell
in love with rayons character and went
all-in
Jared's weight-loss approach was very
different and extremely dangerous
he stopped eating completely which had a
huge impact on his body mind and spirit
he shed a total of 40 pounds for the
role now it's hard to believe that Jared
could ever weigh a hundred and fourteen
pounds but that's how much the actor
weighed while filming Dallas buyers club
I'm a healthy 150 now Shirley's is an
oscar-winning actor who knows a thing or
two about dedication although she's
maintained a healthy weight for most of
her life Shirley's has gained weight for
a role on two separate occasions she
first gained 30 pounds in 2003 when she
portrayed Aileen in the movie monster
but most recently in 2018 Shirley's put
on 50 pounds while playing Marlowe in
the movie Tully
we're the nanny tries to kill the family
and the mama survives and she's
walk with a cane at the end gaining this
much weight was both intense in
exhausting for the naturally toned
celebrity she told ET that this time
around it took her a year and a half to
get back into shape according to the
star gaining and maintaining 50 pounds
was a full-time job how did you do that
oh that's no secret we all know how to
do that and that's a wrap before you go
tell us which transformation surprised
you the most in the comments section
below for more videos from the things
hit that subscribe button and don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up we'll see you next time thanks for
watching